Some various junk that, from the front, looks
like this. And, the world's first orange aligator.
It's episode 19 of IMG!
A new Kinect trick allows you to take photos
with your Xbox, and then build them in Minecraft.
And here's some true Tetris love.
When your car gets covered in snow, let the
snow people drive it. And then, with a little
creativity, prove that money is the root of
all evil...Zombies...
And why spray paint all willy-nilly when you
can paint each individual brick and make a
pixelated Link?
If Greedo was on the "Jersey Shore" it would
suck, but this really blows...
Awesome...oh...
This is how pumpkin pie is made...maybe you'd
prefer some Star Wars cakes, or TV dinner
cupcakes?
But, before you wash it all down, this is
why drinking is like yoga.
This issue of Parent's Magazine is old and
photoshopped, but covering letters always
makes places more fun, especially if it's
accidental.
Ted Williams had an awesome week, and to celebrate,
here are some equally awesome homeless signs...enjoy.
Now, it's time for the worst parenting ever.
We've got grocery shopping, party time, snakes,
pole dancing lessons, champagne, and, "hey
you look angry, take this."
Right now it's Jesus, but, upside down, it's
Satan.
And where's the human covered in paint? Oh, there
he is. There he is. Where is he here?
Well, this is true.
Ok, let's look at some hilariously inappropriate
t-shirts:
Wrong strategy. Wrong age. Wrong...everything...And,
thanks for the warning...
Here's a great vanity plate. And, she is pretty...WOAH,
SQUISHY BALL!
On Facebook, you guys are still at it. Ryan
Tim brought us "Hard Rock," and he also brought
us a most nutritious breakfast.
To see more and submit your favorites, "Like"
us over at Facebook.com/vsaucegaming.
And, i'll leave you today with my favorite
actual questions that were really asked on
Yahoo Answers. Let me know below what question
you would most want answered. And, as always,
thanks for watching.